already uprooted from their homes
thousands of Sudanese are fleeing again
after 8 months of conflict and more than
12,000 people killed the number of
displaced keeps
growing since Friday clashes between
Sudan's Army and the paramilitary rapid
support forces have spread to the state
of Al jazer a previously untouched
region south of Harum its main city had
become a refuge for half a million
people 500,000 idps are in W Med and
they were on the move to Sinar which is
another city it's like an hour's drive
from wad medy but there's fuel shortages
what would have been a normally an hour
trip end up be taking 11 hours so
basically people are just on the move as
the battlefield extends South the city
of wad madani is no longer a safe haven
cra crowds of families are forced to
leave with whatever belongings they can
carry 14,000 people have fled the area
so
far back in April what began as a power
struggle between military ruler abdal
fatah aloran and his Deputy General
Muhammad hamand [__] erupted into open
conflict half the population in Sudan is
in need of humanitarian Aid we are
warning of a looming hunger catastrophe
by next year's lean season if we're
unable to expand access and regularly
deliver food assistance to people
Trapped In conflict hotspots but we've
only managed to reach the Capital One
Time in the last 3 months now the UN
says that funding for Aid is running low
most of the world's attention is focused
elsewhere with Russia's war in Ukraine
and Israel's military campaign on God
meanwhile Kum is a daily Battleground
and War rages on the outskirts of wad
madani in what many fear is a new front
in this war iptm genud Al jazer